Um,
I think they are friends.
I think what's troubling to the American
Jewish community troubling to me is I
think there's been a change of strategy.
And I think that comes as a result of
the fact that,
um,
the United States today is facing a
major challenge in the world.
It's not Russia,
it's not China,
it's not Chavez.
It's,
um,
it's the Arab Muslim world.
We're at war America's at war with two
Muslim countries.
We baby at warroad a third.
Um,
not all Muslims are terrorists,
but most artists are Muslims.
It's a major challenge for the U S and,
um,
I think what we're seeing in this
administration is an effort to deal with
it.
And I think part of that effort is this
notion of linkage that if you could only
solve the Arab Israel conflict,
Messiah will come in the Middle East.
And it's that notion,
that analysis that is motivating
American policy.
And so,
um,
yeah I think friends,
but I think when the president went to
the Middle East is stumble Cairo Rehab
three times he was in a neighborhood of
Jerusalem,
didn't visit Jerusalem,
sent the wrong message,
sent a message that we're reaching out
to the Arab Muslim world at the expense
of our friendship or relationship with
Israel.
I've been focusing on settlements
without focusing on Palestinian
incitement and stuff was another
mistake.
So I think what we're seeing is a policy
which sees itself distancing the United
States from Israel in order to reach out
and in some manner to the Arab Muslim
world.
I don't think it's worked.
And so many of the Jewish community have
been concerned that this nuance or non
nuance changed as is as is.
And I believe as I indicated earlier,
is hurting prospects.
That piece,
cause if Israel does not feel that it's
only ally continues to be its friend
event,
it will not risk.
It will not compromise to the extent
that it has.
And if you take a look at it,
and during the Bush administration,
whether you like Bush or not,
the first president to come out for a
Palestinian state with Bush.
Why?
Because Israel trusted him.
And,
uh,
Sharon trusted him to the point that
when,
when President Bush announced appellate
that America's for a Palestinian state,
prime minister,
Sharon leftist political party because
they were opposed,
um,
disengagement from Gaza happened under
Bush,
um,
the Annapolis.
So when it's closer,
now we have no talks and in Palestinians
and Israelis are talking through
proximity,
which is their 15 kilometers away,
nine miles away.
And I've got to talk through the United
States.